han pasado Ya 60 años desde la
independencia de Argelia frente a
Francia que supuso esta guerra tanto
para Argelia como para Francia Y cómo
han ido las relaciones desde entonces
Bueno creo que la relación entre Francia
y Argelia es una relación por definición
estratégica extremadamente importante
por razones históricas obviamente por
razones geográficas y hoy en día como
muy bien dijo
Por qué entramos en una nueva fase de
relación es cierto pues que la memoria
hace parte de de la historia de del
enlace entre ambos países un enlace que
cuenta con población un enlace que
cuenta con la guerra y con sangre
compartido una relación que cuenta con
una realidad geográfica económica y de
seguridad Entonces estamos de realmente
en algo muy vivo muy intenso tanto por
diplomacia francesa como por supuesto
por Argelia en una región que está
moviéndose que está cambiando vemos lo
que está pasando en Zarra vemos el
Mediterráneo y obviamente hoy en día con
mi ropa Bueno usted ha hablado
precisamente del Sahara y es un punto
importante porque Argelia ha cogido en
este momentos importancias por la guerra
en Ucrania y por la exportación de gas
hacia Europa podría Francia estar
intentando posicionarse como un socio
principal para Argelia en un momento en
el que las relaciones con España quizás
su principal socio en cuanto al gas son
tensas precisamente por el Sáhara sí
creo que hoy estamos realmente en un
momento clave en un momento de
definición de una nueva relación de
darle un nuevo conocimiento de mirar
hacia el porvenir razón por la cual el
presidente Macro hago como habló como
muy bien dijo de la verdad de por
supuesto trabajar sobre la memoria pero
también pues definir objetivos claves
para el porvenir esos objetivos cuentan
obviamente por la economía dado en
cuenta la realidad hoy en día que a
través se Hay ropa ahora démonos cuenta
también de la realidad Francia cuenta
con una producción no a base de gas de
más de 80% de su capacidad y de su
necesidad energética en en todo lo que
necesita Francia la producción del gas
sobre 20% de lo que necesita Francia de
Argelia es de 8%, ahora por supuesto
estamos entrando en una diversificación
hablo de España hablaría de Italia de un
enlace muy fuerte sobre el gas entre
Argelia e Italia pero Italia es Europa y
estamos todos pues miembros de un año
europea que está ganando pues peso en
términos de independencia como bien dijo
Emanuel macco en este principio de año
como presidente de la Unión Europea
dando Pues esa figura de una Unión
Europea más independientes y para usar
una palabra ya compartida por todos los
miembros europeos una de ropa potencia
muy bien volvemos de nuevo a la relación
en concreto de Argelia y Francia como
bien ha indicado usted macron ha hablado
hoy de verdad y reconocimiento en vez de
arrepentimiento que puede significar a
efectos prácticos que puede hacer
Francia en este sentido y cree usted que
Argelia puede reconocer o puede aceptar
esta nueva versión de la relación entre
ambos países pues la tonalidad del
encuentro entre los dos presidentes el
presidente Manuel tanto como el
presidente de Tribuna el presidente de
Argelia es una tonalidad de respeto una
tonalidad a la vez pragmática viendo
hacia el porvenir Entonces es la razón
por la cual el presidente francés
ha creado una comisión de historiadores
para trabajar pues sobre la historia
obviamente porque ahí hubo cruce de
combates cruce de sangre
muchos se han ido en Francia pero
también ya como dijo pasó bastante
tiempo también nuevas generaciones aquí
están y hoy en día viendo pues a nivel
el nuevo peso económico que está ganando
Argelia
el tiempo de pensar por venir a través
de objetivos económicos que van a crear
una nueva influencia compartida ha
llegado